il est 19h et pendant que les criquets
chante
l'équipage de laguiole snack elysées
madiana deux sens thann se réunit pour
faire le point avant le jour j
[Musique]
la logistique est mise au point et le
matériel vérifier minutieusement 500
points wii
seydoux et ce à son point mais bon comme
sommes assez costauds donc ça va
chaque journée c'est devenu par exemple
le matériel c'est dangereux tout pour
l'adjoint petit mont al batikh m'en a
déjà enseigné le goût d'aller en
finition on essaie d'être le maximum à
vol d'oiseau
[Musique]
et là vous allez assister à un passage
obligatoire
la pesée une étape amusantes ou
stressante mais ô combien importante
c'est très important aussi pour le
patron parce qu'il doit savoir ben qui
met sur les bras de l'essai de chaque
côté vous pouvoir mais avoir un travail
optimum un travail efficace parce que si
on met quelqu'un de légers sont en bois
dressés dont on n'aura pas le travail
escompté
l'exercice peut paraître invraisemblable
surprenant et particuliers m sans jamais
changer le monde normalement franchement
pourtant il a toute son importance
la confiance en soi l'équipage ait
souvent a décidé de la travailler à
travers l'exercice du miroir une semaine
de compétition entourée d'hommes
d'adversaires dans des conditions
souvent difficiles physiquement et
émotionnellement et ça ça se travaille
jour j moins 4 pour toute l'équipe
humaniser madiana une préparation
physique et mentale
de quoi entamer ce 35ème tour outils
viable